[Music]
the athletes mindset is their awareness
to stay in the moment and do the best
you can do at the task at hand
whatever that task is but an important
thing for all of us is that we wanted to
stay healthy and get through this with
the energy and the strength that we
currently have and hopefully you can
build upon that versus deteriorate in
any way and not even from a virus
standpoint and the concerns with that
but also just because this time requires
so much extra energy and everything
we're doing from homeschooling to
everybody in the house and patients and
so forth I mean me with four kids here
at home you know and so they're being
healthy getting enough sleep eating well
and having some sort of physical outlet
every day it makes a huge difference
having the patience and perspective for
them because it's difficult for them
currently - we only control us and how
we present ourselves to the world and
part of that is this whether it's family
whether that's work with us or loved
ones whether that's our body and how we
go about our day and carry ourselves as
that beacon of strength and support and
outward love to others that's Chris
health and this is the retro podcast
[Music]
the rich role podcast greetings fellow
life-forms plotting our way through this
parallel universe we call pandemic
how're you guys doing how are you
holding up well coronavirus has canceled
a lot of things but it's more than just
school work and social outings it's also
canceled mic drop races now listen the
world's got big problems lots of people
are suffering right now in unimaginable
ways so it does come off as a bit
insensitive to cry over spilt milk like
your marathon your ultra your Ironman or
even the Olympics getting postponed that
said if you are an athlete the
disappointment is still real very real
and I think it's okay to lament that an
important goal you set for yourself has
simply vanished from the landscape for a
minute but we cannot linger on the past
or a future that will no longer be or on
things that are simply out of our
ability to control the focus needs to
shift to creative solutions for
maintaining our enthusiasm for fitness
in these unusual times and strategies
and tactics for developing creative
routines that keep us engaged with our
physical selves I've been getting a lot
of questions from all of you about how
to accomplish this how to sustain
maintain some engagement with our health
and our fitness so I decided to enlist
my sensei of all matters strength and
endurance Chris how to share his expert
perspective in this latest up teenth
installment of Coaches Corner briefly
for those unfamiliar chris is a two-time
olympian a former professional
triathlete Ironman champion age group
ironman world champion and one of the
world's most respected endurance and
ultra endurance coaches he also happens
to be my coach as well as a very good
friend it's a great conversation that I
think is going to leave you
reinvigorated to push forward in your
athletic journey but first one thing
I've learned in my wellness journey is
that morning habits totally influence
how the rest of our day unfolds and one
of the best daily habits I've adopted is
drinking athletic greens on the daily
it's actually more than a habit athletic
greens has become kind of a ritual for
me right when I'm getting my day started
drinking athletic greens just sets my
whole day straight giving my body all
the good juju it needs right off the bat
to have my best day ever
for those new to athletic greens here's
the scoop their ultimate daily is
basically the best plant-based
all-in-one supplement out there it's
packed with 75 Whole Foods sourced
ingredients specifically designed to
support your body's nutrition needs
across five critical areas of health
including energy immunity gut health
hormonal support and healthy aging it
tastes great it dissolves super easy and
dispenses with anything and everything
artificial no added sugar just the good
stuff it's gluten free dairy free paleo
and vegan plus they have easy travel
packs I bring with me on my
long-distance runs and bike rides for an
easy boost on-the-go consider athletic
greens the ultimate nutritional
insurance I can't recommend it enough if
you're in the US Canada the UK or Europe
listen up you can get 20 free travel
packs valued at 79 bucks with your first
purchase at athletic greens com forward
slash rich roll that's athletic greens
com forward slash rich roll ok so Before
we jump in with Chris I want to do
something a bit different and briefly
check in with my buddy
Mishka Shu Bali you remember Mishka
right from her legendary 500th episode
or his many past appearances on the show
for those brand new to the RRP Mishka is
my stubbornly sober self-deprecating
gravelly voiced sometime runner
singer-songwriter master storyteller and
sage of the written word with a slew of
best-selling Kindle singles to his name
and mishka's got a new audible original
coming out May 1st entitled cold turkey
how to quit drinking by not drinking
so I called him up I did that to
celebrate the seventh anniversary of our
bromance and just because I wanted to
get a little taste for his flavor of
warranty let's do it all right man so
you hit me up the other day asking once
again to come back on the podcast you've
been on the podcast a million times you
were just on the podcast I basically was
like come on bro but you got this new
book coming out and then you hit me with
this heartfelt seven-year bromance of
ursery post the other day and I was like
that was by accident man I can come back
on for a few minutes I went back to my
old Gmail [ __ ] and I found I was like oh
my god it was just it was it's like on
Sunday you know so I'm sorry man my you
know my my GUI Tenderheart it just got
the best of me well I'm glad to be
talking to you you're always welcome
here and it feels like just yesterday I
knocked on the door of that dilapidated
Greenpoint
hovel that you called an apartment and
thank you for the first time walking up
that staircase the stacks of guitars
everywhere and a you know some kind of
roommate I think was there at the same
time lots of pizza boxes it was a
disaster and now what are you doing now
you got like a truck jacked up on cinder
blocks what's happening yeah I was
listening you talk I was just looking
around at the stacks of guitars and man
we've come so far
now you just you just read it's called a
geographic you just took all of that
from Greenpoint and relocated it to
Phoenix where wherever you go there
there you are right exactly man but you
got a house you've come a long way and
I'm proud to be your friend for seven
years I'm growing up as slowly as
possible man okay well all of those
Instagram posts that used to be pictures
of guitars that you were fixing seems to
have now pivoted to old trucks
reparable vehicles from a bygone era I
just I just love damage that's the quote
that's the quote that is the title of
this podcast I just love damage dude I
close call today max I was doing another
podcast my buddy of mine and I fired up
this old 78 dots and that's been in the
yard and then I just looked out and it
was we broke a hose and it was leaking
antifreeze I have my little damaged cat
here too and fortunately I put her in
the house otherwise we would be having a
very different conversation right now
I don't know whether I should be
depressed hearing that story or
entertained well I mean look at it this
way like I found my ideal pokeymon you
know like I found a cat that loves to
drink things that will kill her okay
I like how you transition your fixation
I mean it was a mouse for a while and
now you got this cat you're you you
you're like you have a soft spot for
strays because I think on some level
you're a bit of a stray yourself the
just you know incremental upgrades from
you know from a mouse - yeah - a special
needs cat right dude when you meet her
you all you will flip she's just like
she's just a little noodle and like she
can't walk straight she always her
head's always talked to one side like
you owe her money perfect normal so how
is the how is the sequestration the
lockdown in this era of Cova treating
you well it's not radically different
from my normal day-to-day life which
makes me think that I should make some
changes if we ever emerge from our you
know from our current darkness that's a
sentiment I share yeah the I mean I
think we agree that the most powerful
medication is human contact at least you
know for for mental ailments you know I
miss my people dearly you know and like
like Robin you know she and I went for a
hike the other day you know being
careful too
deserve social distancing and staying
you know apart and then at the end of
our hike like we just looked at each
other mournfully because like I'm a
hugger you know and I hug her when I see
her and I hug her at the end of the
hikes and that's like and I I miss hugs
dude I'm not gonna lie do you think
we're ever gonna get back to hugging and
shaking hands I mean if I'm just putting
my own life at risk yes I will
absolutely hug you no it's just my mom
I'm worried about you know yeah I think
we're all worried about the elders that
we have in our life right now meanwhile
I'm trying to get a visual on the daily
dietary protocol for you I'm envisioning
a lot of like cans of beans half eat and
spread around her kitchen the so far so
good today man I had I had coffee and an
apple and oatmeal for breakfast and then
my girlfriend's just unpacking groceries
now I saw you know bag or thing at kale
hanging out of one of the bags you know
you know couple cans of salts are not
perfect but but a radical improvement do
you remember the [ __ ] that I used to
dude yeah I do very well
the know I'm doing well that is good
that's progress man but I'm gonna chalk
that up to you having a girlfriend no
quarter no quarter well you're healthy
you're getting some running in you're
fixing old trucks and guitars
you're leaning into the sequestration
it's all good man I think I think you're
gonna be fine and the occasion for this
is twofold like I said to celebrate
seven years of being your friend I
celebrate you thank you you've brought a
lot into my life and I appreciate you
and I love you very much the second
being this new audible original that you
sprung on me the other day like hey man
I got this this new thing coming out
like why we didn't even talk about this
the last time you were on the podcast
cold turkey how to quit drinking by not
drinking and now I haven't listened
this yet it's coming out on the first
right yeah me first May first I have a
feeling I'm not gonna like this book you
know looking forward to you not like
because like honestly that I do think
that people really benefit by you and I
having sustained thoughtful considerate
disagreements recorded you know and I I
know we're both deeply invested in
thesis antithesis synthesis you know
that's that is how you get to the higher
plane so um you were in my head the
whole time that I was writing this man
and I was I was writing it and I was
thinking rich is gonna [ __ ] hate this
the basic thesis I take it is that you
can quit drinking without any help from
any other human being and just relying
on your own personal resolve is that is
that the sense that I'm getting from
this cover art that I'm looking out of a
smashed beer can
well that's part one and part two is
where I cop to making it wait having
made it way harder for myself than I had
to you know that but this is what we
rely on you for we want you to have to
do that that's part of your charm is
funny man I used to be the alcohol stunt
man and now I'm the no alcohol stunt man
you know I'm still yes so it's still
pushing the boundaries but but yeah you
know I mean I did it the hard way
and that proves that it can be done even
the hard way and then I do you know so
I'm just saying that the possibility is
there you know that there's a million
different ways to quit drinking and
every single way that leads to you
quitting drinking and staying staying
sober works it's it's real right and but
yeah I mean I do I do
critique myself and say that there are a
lot of ways in which I made it harder
for myself you know one of two of the
things I talked about our nutrition and
community you know you might be you
might be pleasantly surprised well
listen you know I got sober in in in a
treatment center and Alcoholics
Anonymous that's the path that I've
chosen I've seen that path benefit the
lives of countless thousands of people
over the years but I don't begrudge
people finding other ways to get sober I
don't have any judgment on that it's
obviously worked for you I'm not sure I
would recommend your path but I do look
forward to reading this book and I'm
curious why you decided to go with it
being audible only like why didn't you
write it also why is it only an audio
book the it remains to be seen if if we
can get it together we may publish a you
know a book version long you know sort
of like an expanded version of the
audiobook the one of the things that
I've learned and and and part of this is
on you man is that people really respond
to hearing my story in my voice you know
that and I'm sure that like you've
noticed this too like there but there'll
be times where I'm texting somebody
you're emailing somebody and I can't
tell if like if they got the joke or if
I miss the joke or if they're mad at me
or if they're not mad at me but to hear
to hear something like this in
somebody's own voice I think there's a
whole different level of communication
and specificity that people here and
that people understand you know and part
of that is from being on the podcast and
seeing the way that people respond to
you know tell us bickering in public
well there is something curiously and
and confounding ly appealing about your
gravelly voiced drawl that seems to draw
people into your life and all its drama
I I have a like this the whole plague
sort of meltdown here happen when I was
like halfway through getting a crown
done on one of my teeth and it's I feel
like it's starting to go bad and I just
talked to a dentist and he was like oh
well you should you know gargle with
this bleach solution and I was like bro
been waiting my whole life for this all
right man well I told you I'd give you
ten minutes that's a pretty good place
to put
but I do want to say that my heart goes
out to anybody right now in this bizarre
moment that we find ourselves in who is
in the early throes of attempting
sobriety it's got to be really difficult
to be stuck at home trying to you know
grapple with your inner demons and stay
away from substances you know I did it
by virtue of community you touched on
community even though you you know kind
of have this self reliant narrative you
know you did say the community is really
important to you and I think it's
important to anybody who's getting sober
so I do encourage everybody to check out
this book if this is the only community
that you can find get sober at Hunt well
you're stuck at home and and and make
use of the virtual communities that we
all have to not keep your demons private
and secret yeah it's it is free for the
month of May through audible and yeah
and that was that was really important
to me was that I just sort of go out to
everybody in anybody who needs it for
this month of May and and I will rich I
will back up exactly what you said and
you know to those people out there who
are suffering in early sobriety and you
feel like you're totally alone know that
rich and I are both thinking about you
were sending love support positive vibes
whatever you want to call it where
you're you're in our heads you're in our
hearts we're thinking about you yeah and
as I've said many times before my DMS
are open on Twitter and Instagram if
anybody is is struggling with an
addiction problem it's very difficult
for me to respond to everybody but I
always do my best to try to communicate
and have a dialogue with anybody who's
going through that right now so feel
free to reach out to me in that way
myself as well all right man
the book is cold turkey it's available
on audible which is also Amazon and I
checked we're recording this on Monday
it wasn't up yet so it's gonna be a
little bit before it actually appears on
the website is it the third that it's
gonna be visible I think it's
I think it's April 30th or me first I'm
not sure which but but yeah I'll be up
shortly alright man well I look forward
to giving it a listen and I love you
brother
thanks for coming in seven years I can't
believe it let's do seven more one of
these days we're actually gonna go for a
run I know alright man alright peace out
until I can see you in person next time
and you drop by the studio alright peace
out brother later
that was fun right I love that guy given
that we are now resorting more and more
to remote recording maybe I'll do more
short check-in segments in the future
let me know what you guys think hey
listen when you're stressed where does
that tension show up in your body for me
it's always in my neck and lower back
whether it's from training overload work
stress or too many zoom calls faragon
has been an absolute game-changing
treatment when it comes to relieving the
pain and tension in my body naturally
this thing is super legit it's a
straight-up professional-grade
percussive therapy device that uses a
scientifically calibrated combination of
depth
speed and power to release deep muscle
tension break up scar tissue increase
blood and lymphatic flow and improve
lactic acid clearance over the last few
years I've developed some sciatica that
causes quite a bit of pain and
discomfort in my lower back and also
down my left leg and it's super
uncomfortable it makes it hard to sleep
sometimes so I got that there agon a
couple months ago I downloaded the
mobile app and it gave me this very
precise protocol for how to use the
device to deal with my specific dilemma
now I'm not one for hyperbole I've tried
a lot of treatments and protocols over
the year so I wasn't super optimistic
about how much this was gonna help but I
got to tell you it has helped me
tremendously and it's now become a daily
routine for me I can't recommend this
thing more highly and right now you can
try Thera gong risk-free for 30 days by
going to thier gong calm slash rich roll
for a limited time my listeners can get
up to 150 dollars off all you got to do
is go to thier gong comp slash rich roll
that's thier again.com slash rich roll
for up to one hundred and fifty dollars
off and finally we're brought to you
today by seed probiotic supplements
foods beverages they're exploding there
like everywhere you can even get
probiotic ice cream these days what is
that about at the same time there's
still a lot of confusion
about what probiotics are and how they
work and not all probiotics are created
the same believe me there's a lot of
nonsense out there seed was founded to
bring much needed precision and efficacy
to the global probiotics market their
flagship daily symbiotic combines 24
different probiotic strains in one dose
strains not found in yogurt or other
fermented foods but rather already
naturally occurring in the human body
the benefits go beyond your gut the
daily symbiotic includes clinically
studied probiotic strains that deliver
core benefits to the gastrointestinal
system which in turn influence systemic
health including skin heart and gut
immune function I've been taking it ever
since seeds founders are cots and Rajah
der ER visited the podcast that was
episode 445 check it out if you missed
it I could tell you this I definitely
feel the difference my digestion is
better my mood is stabilized in my
disposition just seems more even to
learn more about the science behind seed
head on over to seed com4 slash rich
roll or use the code rich roll for 20%
off your first month of the daily
symbiotic that's e-comm for such rich
roll or use code rich roll at checkout
expertise aside my favorite thing about
Chris and the reason he is here with us
today is really his attitude he's just
so grounded and positive setting aside
his amazing expertise and I like the
fact that he values fun as much as
standing on a podium so today we're
gonna talk about how to adapt our
workouts to quarantine how to keep up
healthy habits in the home in this
hectic time and how to create our own
goals and personal adventures in lieu of
canceled braces it's a pretty
light-hearted conversation I think it's
going to bring you some good perspective
along with tangible things that you can
do now to stay sane if your workout or
training life has been turned upside
down by virtue of coronavirus May this
exchange lift your spirits and leave you
inspired to push forward in your athlete
journey during these times so this is me
and Chris how
well it's going right aren't we all sort
of just going observing day by day
seeing this is unlike yeah no frame of
reference to which to compare this to
that's for sure any of us that's for
sure
yeah I would say that you and I are in a
privileged situation in that we're still
both able to do what we do
professionally and also and we talked
about this previously you know my
day-to-day life is not that dramatically
changed I know yours isn't all that I
mean we can't go to the pool and there's
trails we can't go to and the like but
we both work from home we have our kids
at home yep my family is safe and
healthy and I know that yours is as well
yeah so we have that to be grateful for
but that doesn't mean that there aren't
a lot of people out there suffering in a
myriad of different ways and I want to
be sensitive to that as we kind of you
know discuss the perils of what it means
to be an athlete in this unique moment
yeah yeah I mean I've compared it to the
twilight zone right like it's a show
that none of our kids know but when we
were younger it just sort of this weird
moment in time where everything sort of
stops and we're living in a parallel
universe it seems like and I've been
calling it to my athletes and the people
I talked to as stoppage-time it's like
that extra time on a soccer game where
you're like how did they make up extra
time on the 90 minutes for a soccer game
you know we're all in timeout yeah so
it's just like stoppage time and that's
that's actually the unique thing that I
keep talking to so many about is how do
we want a kick out of this right it is
there's so many negative aspects to
what's happening and there's a lot of
pain and a lot of hurt in the world and
of course tragedy and numerous numerous
tragedies but for us as we are working
our way through this it's also a daily
process of how do we want to kick out of
this how do we want to contribute who do
we want to be on the other side of this
not just as athletes but as human beings
how do we want to remember this this
experience was it meaningful did we help
did we have an impact you know did we
give energy to others or did we just sit
in our own energy these months for what
it's worth right now we're six eight
weeks and it's months and so that's the
important thing for me that I always
remind people of not only a fitness and
who we want to be as an athlete on the
other side but also just as human beings
mm-hmm yeah I mean I think through the
lens of what it means to be an athlete
in this moment the athlete mantra is and
always has been process
/ results you know the journey over the
destination it's not about race results
it's about showing up day in and day out
and now with races removed calendars
cancelled I mean today was supposed to
be the Boston Marathon it's a moment
where we're all really being compelled
to put this philosophy to the test a
moment where athletes are really being
compelled to face whether or not it
truly is about the process you know this
moment that will separate out the strong
the ones who can manage setback and
disappointment and obstacles and
everything that is being thrown in our
direction right now whether you're an
athlete or not and the capacity that we
have to leverage it to become better not
just as athletes but as people yeah yeah
for sure and I mean for those that were
ahead the Boston Marathon today right
would have had it and then had it
circled on their schedule for such a
long time I've said to my athletes that
would have done Boston if you look back
on the experience of training for this
one day the cumulative little
experiences that you had in training and
the things you overcame and the
sacrifices you made and the joy you had
in it is way more than just one day will
deliver then these next three four or
five hours in the event
we'll deliver it's the last six eight
months of cumulative micro experiences
joy smiles pain difficulty hardship
sacrifice discipline resilience that is
what accumulates way more than just one
day sure the emotions are magnified in
this day because it's a vent day it's
race day it's competition it's the
energy of others in the crowd but if you
think back would you trade your fitness
and your strength and the experiences
and the joy and the overcoming of the
last six eight nine ten months to get
ready for this for just one day probably
not if you look at it truly as a human
right mm-hmm and that's the part that's
so fascinating to me that once people
start looking back especially athletes
start looking back and going huh
actually yes Here I am at event day but
the last eight nine ten months of course
we want to see it to fruition and see
what we're capable of and we still can
do that those haven't gone anywhere it
might not be today it might be in six
months or eight months or in a year but
the cumulative experiences of what this
has been has shaped us so much more than
what one day can ever deliver yeah it
sounds pithy and trite to say you know
it's not about the race it is
disappointing if you've put a lot of
energy and time and a lot of imagination
and visioning into you know what it
would be like to run the Boston Marathon
for example so it's okay to have some
level of disappointment that you can't
participate in that but you need to
reboot quickly and recognize that in
truth it is about what you put into it I
mean you're somebody who's been an
athlete your entire life I mean I don't
even know if you could count the number
of races and events that you've
participated in but I'd be willing to
bet my life that when you reflect back
upon everything that brought you to
today those moments of crossing finish
lines or part two
a painting in you know exciting events
are just the tiniest fraction of what
you appreciate about everything that
you've put into becoming the person that
you are today
yes it's it's all about the experience
right I said the other day it's I'd
rather have the small payouts versus the
lump sum payout right it's all those
days and experiences and friendships and
tears and difficulties and laughs and
camaraderie in my training years along
the way that have created me
that have created the personality I am -
and how I live today and how I coach if
I only went by these super type-a
competitive events that I've done man
I'd be a robot well I might be partially
aspects of your character although I
would say that you have you've grown
tremendously in the period of time that
I've known you yeah but that being said
it is the accumulation of all the daily
payouts I call it daily payout right and
that's one thing in this time that I try
to remember for myself as well because
you know my events and the things that I
was getting ready for are also not going
to happen and I've completely had to
shift what I do for training and how I
train I love swimming in the pool and I
love my friends and my Master's group
and the camaraderie and we had a big
event planned for this summer as in
swimming across Lake Tahoe and that's
not gonna happen right now I can't even
get in the pool some are swimming in the
bay and so forth but right ahead I just
can't do that we may in cold water at
all odd hours putting wet suits on and
sharks and the whole thing I just I'm
too much of a wimp for that but that
being said it's like wait a moment what
do I enjoy about this and what is the
athletes mindset in this and that is
showing up every day figuring out how
I'm going to be better tomorrow than I
am today
being prepared being healthy being fit
eating well the proper prep for in order
to absorb that workout which takes
no talent you don't have to be an elite
athlete to be that we've talked about
this on podcast and then executing and
then feeling good about that and
especially in this time what I love
about this is it's something for you
each day
and it allows you to have more energy to
give to others by doing something for
ourselves we can sort of take a exhale a
deep breath and go alright I took care
of myself it that it's not selfish
because you have more energy to give to
others more patience more understanding
more perspective when you have that
opportunity to do some training like an
athlete for yourself every day the
athlete mindset is also about building
resilience and becoming efficient in
your discipline and building you know
the capacity to endure faced and
overcome obstacles and of course these
are life lessons and I think these are
skill sets that are required of us now
in a way that we couldn't have predicted
and I think recognizing that innate
capacity that the athlete has connecting
with that is another way of being of
service to the people around you who
might not have that level of acumen with
respect to those specific skills and I
think as an athlete dealing with the
setbacks and the inability to go out and
do what we like to do is just another
opportunity to build resilience in a
different way that will make you
ultimately a more mindful and present
and and resilient athlete to be able to
handle like this kind of challenge is
different from getting a flat tire in an
Ironman or something like yeah but
nonetheless it's an obstacle right and
so we haven't we can ply that capacity
that we have or we can test ourselves or
use it as a way of reflecting more
deeply upon the you know the blind spots
that we still have and the work that
remains to be done
and it's a daily habit right all those
little failures micro failures during
the day or in our training weeks or that
flat tire
or how we deal with adversity those are
habits that we've seen and worked
through and created and seen and work
through again and that prepares us for
the bigger ones like this current
environment and again we have the
ability because of those daily habits
and our familiarity with being
persistent and disciplined and resilient
like you say to stand as sort of beacons
in this current environment not that
we're better than anybody it's more just
that we stand with our consistency and
our willingness to show up every day as
people who can contribute contribute
outwardly to others and helping and
focusing on that as well it is hard
right now to fathom a moment in time
where thousands of people are gonna
descend upon a starting line somewhere
to participate in an event where people
are gonna be sweating all over each
other yeah I presume at some point we
will achieve some level of stasis where
that's possible but right now I you know
I I don't know how long it's gonna be
before something like that will be
permissible oh yeah so I'm interested in
how your athletes are you know dealing
with that right now I know you're doing
these periodic zoom calls and you've
been putting out podcasts on this
subject matter yeah I mean for us it's
more a question of being ready for when
those opportunities arise right so
that's in the training that's in our
mindset that's in our nutrition that's
in our sleep in our recovery all the
modes that we sort of call training
right but it's also how will I kick out
of this
armed with more tools in my toolbox
because of the things I had to do in
this time that make me a more complete
athlete for when that time comes right
so the strength work that we're doing or
more sort of confined to the home and
using you know backpacks with weights in
them and doing step ups instead of
running because the trails might be
closed and doing new creative type of
thing
that we're noticing strength from and
integrity from in our body that then we
hopefully can integrate on the other
side when things loosen up a little bit
and we're able to do all three or four
the activities that we usually do to
also have this as part of our toolbox
and again to make us a more complete
athlete hmm the second piece there too
is that I've told my athletes and in a
lot of our conversations is be ready for
a second half of the year or maybe
early next year 2021 where a lot of
events will open up and the race
directors will be desperate to offer
because there are a small business right
and they're gonna want to get out there
and offer their services in this case
their events and many people a haven't
been able to train or homeschooling or
family or lock down and so forth as well
as your ability to be ready on a whims
notice or within a few weeks notice to
say man that's an event I would have
always have loved to have done and now
they're giving me an opportunity to do
it others might be busy with work or
can't afford to travel or any of those
things
so that's secondly that an opportunity
that might arise that can arise that I
feel will arise for many events and so
forth to be ready for that to take this
once-in-a-lifetime circumstance and turn
it into an opportunity so we want to
kick out of it like that as well as be
ready for it and for the cancelled
events it's more a question of not a
question of when it will happen but how
it will happen to us will we still be
the athletes we said we would be hmm
yeah it is
a unique moment as well by dint of the
fact that you know when you're when
you're looking at runners and
triathletes traditionally not huge fans
of strength work and you know the little
you know the stretching and and the
recovery you know kind of protocols
those all fall by the wayside
especially with the time crunched
athlete they're like I need to get my
volume and I got
My Ride in whatever it is now because a
lot of that is being stripped away there
is an opening to refocus and prioritize
some of those things that ultimately
make you a more bulletproof athlete long
term you know the step ups and the you
know I've got a weighted vest and you
know doing those kinds of things that
that you know I just know speaking for
me personally like those always come
last when they should come first and now
we have an opportunity to put them first
which will make you more resilient and
and you know injury proof and things
that serve you over the long haul we
have a sense of urgency usually with our
training as we're getting ready for an
event we have an a date mark on the
calendar in the future and we have a
certain amount of time to get ready for
it and if we were all super disciplined
and prepared we would start very far out
and methodically and healthy build
towards that event but that's not the
life and the reality any of us live
right we have jobs we have families with
other things so of course as the event
approaches whether it's six months away
or you know three months there's a sense
of urgency towards that event but now in
this window to work on technique to work
on footwork have somebody videotape you
or use your phone to get some insight on
what you look like and how you're
landing in your running stride or how
you're cycling on a trainer and your
setup and your position all things that
you usually wouldn't mess with because
you have an event again an opportunity
to come out of this as a better athlete
you can go back to the regular training
you were doing maybe not even include
any of the strength or Core chassis
integrity work but you could be better
technique wise you could be a better
cyclist have a higher cadence later on
your food feet running less heel strike
all those things you add all that up it
makes a big difference for when you
increase the volume again and increase
those hours that you're doing that new
technique and quickly you will notice
you are faster stronger better smarter
from this window this
[ __ ] time if social media is any
indication of anything and it is
certainly an unreliable source of you
know for for a lot of things but what
I've noticed just kind of you know
observing other people's behavior it
seems to divide between people who are
just letting everything go and and you
know kind of slinking into the couch and
others who are so out of their minds
right now that they're concocting crazy
fitness challenges to keep them engaged
like the other end of the polarity which
you know I'm kind of divided on on the
one hand like I applaud the creativity
that goes into trying to come up with
some kind of wacky thing to do to excite
people and keep yourself engaged with
your fitness but I also think this is
not the moment to be wearing yourself
out unnecessarily because we need our
immune systems to be functioning
optimally at the moment absolutely but
that's not sexy right like doing the
kind of little things and the stuff that
normally you wouldn't pay attention to
that are important but don't necessarily
trend on Instagram oh for sure I mean
all those challenges I was laughing the
other day because it's a little bit
short termism right like great you've
done that now what are you gonna do in
three four or five months from now when
you're still stuck or or six weeks from
now you're gonna I wouldn't want anybody
to be burnt out or have an injury
because that would just magnify the
current situation you imagine now you
have the desire and the time and the
ability to train or work on your craft
and you're injured and can't that would
make it even worse and so you are
totally right with trying to avoid
injury and staying healthy and staying
strong and getting the proper recovery
and that's another thing you can work on
in this time for example just writing
down or in the morning or in the evening
after the day journaling and aspect of
how did I take care of my strengths
today how did I take care of my training
modality today my sleep my recovery my
nutrition you go through those five
things right and say
good good could be better and so forth
you do that for the next six weeks your
mindset and how you go about training on
what you look for versus just fatigue on
how you go to bed at night will change
dramatically because you'll recognize
all the little tweaks and inputs that
are part of being a true wholesome
holistic athlete that takes into all
those things into account right mm-hmm
yeah I mean thinking of my own
relationship to fitness and training I
don't need a lot of external motivation
I look forward to it I enjoy it it's
often the highlight of my day to be able
to go out and be in nature and focus on
the breath and you know do what we do
but I also am aware that that's not the
case for a lot of people there are you
know there's a certain subset of people
that need that external motivation in
the form of a goal and that's typically
a race right setting a date on the
calendar having something to work
towards that gets people out of bed and
engaged in a way that they wouldn't
otherwise so short of that with our
inability to be able to do that right
now like what are you telling your
athletes who might be struggling with
that motivation to stay on it and kind
of maintain that that quiet daily
discipline well we have what we call
self curated events right so if you are
interested in doing something there's so
many ideas for yourself to be completed
out there and are successfully done I
had a guy in New York he's stuck not
really able to get out on trails and so
in a few months he turns 44 and he's an
ultra runner but he's never run a 10k
under his age and so he's gonna try to
run a 10k when we're doing speed work
and shorter stuff and more explosive
stuff and strength work in order for him
to run a 10k in under 44 minutes so
there's different things one your age
right in this case he's 44 he's doing a
10k but there's others in other parts of
the country who are going to go out and
for there
a second birthday run 42 miles or 42
kilometers or with their family they're
doing what you and I talked about a few
months ago with writing or running or
getting through every street in their
town either on a mountain bike or
running or hiking or walking I mean it's
phenomenal but the idea is that people
are coming up with in this time like you
even mentioned earlier yes you don't
have to be super type-a and focused on
what you can do and break a treadmill
world record but you can enter it versus
the other end of the spectrum sitting on
the couch and sort of falling into the
creases which is fine on some days too
but there's a healthy spot in between
with family in many cases to take on
this new time this against Amish time of
sort of looking around you and going I
have plenty of events I can do there's
beautiful opportunities that might open
up so let's say this loosens up a little
bit in a few weeks or even a few months
and then use groups of ten or less right
which i think is going next sort of all
right smaller groups of ten or less so
let's say if that's an opportunity to
say with your friends to go on a hike or
take a long run together or do a sort of
self curated Ironman or triathlon
together I have an athlete he's running
his first marathon he can't do it
anywhere on the roads so he's gonna do
it at the track
not everybody's thing right but it's
still something that he can put his time
in and compare it to others and and
achieve something and that's the great
thing about me all the the watches today
right and Strava and it is up there it
is a valid real time real number and
there's your competitive juices right
there too right
so again self curated and some creative
ideas that allow you to swing both legs
out of bed in the morning and are
excited to do nothing major you don't
have to workout three four hours a day
because there's definitely those right
now too that they have a lot of time on
their hands and all they want to do is
train but just so that you get in your
healthy hour hour and a half 45 minutes
a day and you're progressing towards
something
well you can see the benefits of your
discipline consistency resilience and
hard work what is it look like for you
right now I mean I know that trails are
closed up there are you able to get out
on your bike
what is the outside version of your
daily routine look like the outside
version is currently yes a lot of
cycling but like a lot of the roads that
you're familiar with that I ride up here
are closed like Mount Tam is closed all
the pipe gates are down so you can't
even ride your bike up there so it is on
the regular roads and it is sort of
Groundhog Day riding out the same road
every day just to get to West Marin and
so on but I can't complain because it's
beautiful cycling once you're out there
and there's a lot of choices there's a
lot of home gym work that I'm doing
because I'm writing the routines and
plans and ideas and trying to mix a
bunch of concepts together for athletes
that are stuck in New York City or in LA
or in Atlanta or New Orleans that really
can't get out like they really do need
to stay in their house and for them to
sort of get a good hour in where they're
getting some sort of muscular endurance
work in as well so I'm testing and
playing with a lot of those ideas mmm so
it's a lot of strength it's a lot of
cycling it's stretch cords for swimming
mm-hmm I put a big stretch cords video
out there in order to help people sort
of get their mechanics right with that
but and then a little bit of running but
again the trails are closed and you know
I'd been dealing with a little bit of a
hamstring issue for the last few weeks
ever since its hello the the race we did
in March which was basically the last
event in the world before did we know
exactly exactly
a funny side note on that as I got sick
about six eight days after that like
really stick by um I had a stomach bug
of some sort but at first it on set was
fever lethargic you know not enough of a
fever to really like knock me down but I
was like gosh I feel awful
and us like great if we just spent you
know three days on Catalina with 500
athletes from around the world and I'm
the guy that walks into Marin and shuts
down the schools because I have right
that's like oh no my kids we're all just
looking at me like really dad really
you're gonna be the guy but luckily you
know you're patient zero for Moran
exactly but luckily within 24 hours it
was gone I was very sick but luckily it
was not that but that being said Otello
is basically our last event and so since
then I've been sort of nursing and being
smart with my running because again I
don't I think this will take a lot
longer than we believe you know to
really get out there and run again I
want to be smart and save that for the
future this summer that weather turning
for us in California and being able to
run the trails or run out on the roads
and not be hampered by an injury so I'm
focusing on strength and cycling right
now yeah it is interesting that all the
trails are closed they you know they're
closed down here as well and I
understand the logic of closing down the
larger parks Mount Tam or Malibu Creek
State Park Runyon Canyon like some of
the more heavily trafficked trails
around Los Angeles but right out my
backyard are dozens of trails that
nobody ever goes on yeah I'm sort of
confounded by you know not being able to
use them and then I run on the road and
I'm encountering all these people and
car it just seems way more unsafe to be
on the road and to be completely alone
on the tree I understand like if you get
hurt on a trail and then yeah they have
to medevac you out or something like
that you're putting a strain on the
healthcare system so I get it and I
respect that but you know I'm having my
own interior kind of like Battle of
frustration with that right now as well
as possessiveness right like our trails
as that was two three weekends in Marin
you're like where are all these people
covers right that was the initial thing
suddenly I go out on these trails where
I don't see anybody and there be just
countless people out all of a sudden
yeah I'm like where have you been
so there's a little bit of that but it's
also what I learned about when I was in
Alaska this summer is that I think it's
like of all the national parks and state
parks most and 99% of people never make
it further than a a mile from the
parking lot hmm so wherever they're
parking right so even for your trails
they're hiking a maybe a mile or a mile
and a half in and a mile and a half out
so where we run which is further than a
mile and a half in it's desolate it's
still empty but that's why in a lot of
respects they're closing them too
because of that massive influx of people
who are then using the trails and all
they see is all these people not social
distancing or almost impossible social
distance in that confined space leaving
in that sort of what's happening five
miles into the trail or ten miles is you
know there's probably wildlife going
crazy right now just yeah going finally
we get our neighborhood back right yeah
it's it's uh it's interesting how you
know I ate in my about what I should you
know I could sneak into this trail and
no one would know and I was like I can't
do it you know yeah ya know it's and
it's hard because knowing the trails as
well as we do and all of the miles that
we could go not just for training
purposes but truly just be away from
people to actually physically distance
properly but again we can apply our
knowledge because one wrong is there
none is it wrong right you can't just
head out there so with us in Marin
though I will correct that is you can
still use the trails here it's just you
can't drive your car to the trailhead oh
I still can go out my door and run the
mountain all the way to Stinson and back
but I'm not allowed to drive and park at
the trailhead park there yeah hmm so
that interesting limits it for a lot of
people because now you're a mile or two
away from the trailhead now how far you
gonna go in and so it's it's emptied it
out a little bit yeah for sure that's
different
all the trailheads around here or are
taped off with yellow police station
yeah we don't have that even
these tiny obscure ones yeah we do not
have that so you know that's difference
but it gives us an opportunity again to
try different things right like right
athletes doing things on the road that
they would have never done or at the
track like one of the things that my
athletes have commented on is that well
because the schools are closed the
conflict with the track with that you're
not allowed to be on the track during
school hours is no longer there so we
get right tracks to our advantage now we
do speed work and leg turnover and
drills and strides and high knees and
you know all the little and track drills
that you would do that you'd never have
access to okay so it's this opposite
opportunity the track at the local high
school near my house is closed off oh
now you've been allowed to get into that
Wow
do you have any athletes who are you
know you know in a more complete
lockdown situation like people in New
York or people that can't leave their
you know people in Spain that can't
leave their Apartments at all and don't
have a treadmill or everything for sure
I definitely have some international
athletes where they're really really
stuck to their building they can go out
on the street but it's only limited
hours and Manila for example I have an
athlete and so he's in a parking garage
doing his running and hill repeats and
so forth and then he goes his buildings
right in his own parking garage right
right oh then I'll go back up to his
apartment and he says it's a little
surreal sweating in the same place where
and two hours from now I will be sitting
and having dinner you know but it is
what it is right the same as New York I
mean it's so hard in New York right now
for my athletes I mean a you have to be
covered face you're covering right for
them for the virus but also you know how
much social distancing physical
distancing can you do when you're
running and that's why those New York
Times articles are so accurate about
okay running in New York City you need
15 20 feet for a coffee or you know
somebody spitting mhmmm so what do you
what are you gonna do like you're then
you're dodging a lot of space if you're
going 15 to 20 feet around people while
you're running pretty significantly good
speeds
it's it's very complicated but again
we're really making up for it with a
fair amount of whether it's jump rope or
step ups or leaps and lunges and doing a
lot of routines where we're just going
through each exercise with no stopping
so just these circuits in order just to
keep that sort of endurance mode going
keep the heart rate elevated keep you
challenged different muscle groups and
do that for 30 40 50 minutes what I call
grinds and you've seen on your training
plan too and just sort of at least
you're getting sort of that steady
recruitment of muscular fatigue and
creating muscular endurance lindsay
crouse who writes about running and
other things for the new york times
she's been on the podcast she posted on
Instagram the other day like she's out
running in the streets with a mask on
and she said something to the effect of
if we just call it altitude training you
know these masks we'd probably get wider
adoption yeah it's a broadening thing No
yes it's a marketing thing if the
message were you run with these things
you increase your vo2 max by 7% right
everybody would have right exactly so I
hope that was clever for sure but I mean
we see the same thing cycling - right
right and it becomes complicated like
cycling you think you can ride with
other people but you really can't
because it's ingrained in us so much
that you know you're not paying
attention and you turn your head and for
lack of a better description you blow us
not rocket right or something like that
next thing you know you're like oh right
like you just you have to be so careful
and I think a lot of that is going to
keep us sort of unalloyed for many many
months to come even on the other side of
this like was I really being sanitary
there was I really being smart there and
so the whole approach to how we do
fitness and training in a larger group
is going to have some repercussions here
mentally and culturally as well down the
road our endurance is so low locked in
our head lifestyle might become quite
popular
right yeah I've been out riding my bike
and the social distancing parameters
when you're riding up behind somebody I
mean you have to have a very wide berth
because for the very reasons he just
stated like that person expectorate sin
a certain way that eres Eliza's and then
and you're behind I mean you know and I
see you know there's a lot of cycling in
my area and I see creep rides out people
in packs riding together and I think
what are you doing I don't understand
yeah I'll like you know either just pull
over and let the person get way ahead or
all go as far around them and try to
pass them as quickly as possible in it
and I'm thinking this is so strange that
this is what's going through my mind and
this is a reality that we're in but it
is and then I think should I even be on
a bike at all out here yeah I've gone
through the same I've gone through the
same that same question should I even be
on a bike especially on the busy days
like a Saturday or Sunday because yeah
weekends I think are off yeah I'm
definitely not a germophobe but I get a
little freaked out not a little I
definitely my eyes I'm paying close
attention to where the next cyclist is
in front of me and behind me because I
don't want to be the guy in front of
them and not thinking just do something
stupid or cough or something cuz it goes
so far when we're on our bikes and then
as well as I don't want to be behind
somebody that out of fairness to them
they're not maybe they don't even know
that I'm there mm-hmm and so it's
definitely has to be empty roads
currently and again the important thing
for all of us is that we wanted to stay
healthy and get through this with the
energy and the strength that we that we
currently have and hopefully can build
upon that versus deteriorate in any way
and not even from a from a virus
standpoint and the concerns with that
but also just because this time requires
so much extra energy and everything
we're doing from homeschooling to
everybody in the house and patients and
so forth I mean me with four kids here
at home it's an all of them teenagers
mm-hmm you can just imagine how they're
all staring at me going you gotta be
kidding it we're so sick and tired of
you
yeah but you know and so they're being
healthy getting enough sleep eating well
and having some sort of physical outlet
every day makes a huge difference on
having the patience and perspective for
them because it's difficult for them
currently - yeah very hard I would say
without a doubt the most difficult
aspect of this entire thing so far for
myself and my wife has been trying to
navigate our 16 year old daughter who's
really struggling it's been very
traumatic and difficult for her and you
know I thought I knew a few things about
parenting and this is really putting it
to the test and I just know that left to
my own devices if I'm not taking care of
myself that I'm gonna miss step in how
I'm you know parenting her and so it's
important and you know I guess on some
level of mandatory that I'm training and
doing what I need to do to be as fit
mentally and as emotionally as possible
as much as physically and I think the
thing I keep reflecting back upon is you
know and this is something that that
that you've talked about is where you
know what do I wanna who do I want to be
when this is done you know at some point
this will lift and we will adopt some
new form of normal but nonetheless we
will emerge back into our lives
do I want to reflect back on this as
something that I survived or endured or
do I want to look back on it and say you
know I really leveraged this to think
more deeply about who I want to be what
I want to express the kind of person you
know I want to I want to I want to be in
the world and I think despite the
cacophony of distractions and parenting
and living in close quarters and all of
that there still is I would imagine for
almost everybody more opportunity for
quietude and reflection and with that
you know the ability to develop greater
clarity about what it is that you want
to do and be
and I think training plays a large part
in that but also understanding you know
the opportunity that's built into this
for all of us and I say that again
in total sensitivity to you know people
that are having a really hard time right
now jobs are being lost and people are
being furloughed and there are plenty of
people health care workers and supply
chain workers who are out you know don't
have the luxury of being sequestered and
are out you know taking care of business
for the betterment of all of us and my
heart goes out to all of those people
you know I'm not one of those so I can I
can I can sympathize but I don't want to
say that I can empathize because I'm not
walking in your shoes it's incredibly
difficult and stressful and yet I think
there is this unprecedented moment where
we need to identify the opportunity and
and and attack that and find a way to
leverage it so that we can emerge better
rather than weakened from this
experience for sure for sure I mean and
also it's going to be of memory for all
of us regardless how it hit us whether
in a positive way in a negative way
that's the unique thing about this it
hit the brakes on the entire world and
we're all gonna all remember this
forever our teenagers our younger
children us as adults 20-somethings
30-somethings everybody has been
impacted by this everybody's going to
remember this time right and people have
been saying it's our 9/11 moment or this
and that but it has hit so many more
spectrums of society and there's a lot
of ways we don't control we don't know
how it hits everybody so all we know is
how it hits us doesn't mean we don't
have empathy and care and respect for
those who are working through this and
health care workers and those who've
been hit by tragedy or those who are
losing their jobs and so forth but it
hits every one of us individually and so
what
we going to do with it and that's what
we said earlier is how do we want to
kick out of this but also how do we make
it memorable and and it's going to be
memorable either way so if that is going
to be memorable either way how do we
want it to be memorable
you know positive meaningful caring
thoughtful family sharing joyous way for
others it's not it's not going to be
that but we don't control that and it's
like you know it it's I was reminded of
that Viktor Frankl quote right if you
can't change or control the external
circumstances change yourself or you
know your own internal circumstances and
that's one of those this is one of those
times that we are we only control us and
how we present ourselves to the world
and part of that is this whether it's
family whether that's work whether it's
our loved ones whether that's our body
and how we go about our day and carry
ourselves as that beacon of strength and
support and outward love to others yeah
I can think of only a handful of other
moments in my life where the world sort
of stopped
yeah there's 9/11 there's when Princess
Diana you know died there's no J you
know there's certain things like that
but this is uniquely different from all
of those in that it is global and is
impacting all of us and there's never
been an instance in which we had to stay
home and couldn't go about our day yeah
and and I think with that it gives it
gives this experience a certain quality
but I think has the power to unite us
there's a commonality of experience that
we're all sharing right now but I fear
the divisive nasai see and I think
there's a certain kind of toxic
environment out there that if we're not
really paying attention to ourselves and
and you know focusing on our priorities
and and and really striving to be that
beacon that one could succumb to and
there's a so there's this these opposing
forces of the the kind of unifying
aspect of this that can be uplifting
versus this destructive you know force
of negativity that I see out there is we
know for sure I mean we watched as a
joke not as a joke but with with
intention but it was funny
we watched Groundhog Day the other day
the Bill Murray movie and it was weird
because I've watched that a few times
but I never really took the message as
clearly as it was as a when I watched it
this time with regards to how he was
just being indifferent about everything
right and just like smoking and doing
all kinds of getting drunk and being a
jerk but then once he started paying
attention to the lives around him and
caring and giving he found fulfillment
in that repetition right he found love
that finally broke the loop but he
fulfillment despite the day continuing
he was fine with it because he was
giving and he was focused on externally
helping others versus just focusing on
on on on what he get out of a daily day
repeating itself over and over again but
anyway I mean it's Bill Murray I mean he
can only get so much message but I
thought it was interesting because here
we are we're living a very similar
Groundhog Day like I don't know how many
times over the last few weeks I've said
like what day is it
I'm not even they all feel the same
right right with the kids home there's
no sort of weekend vs. day but as soon
as the process takes over like we were
saying earlier and knowing what we need
to execute on every day whether work
with a family whether training whatever
it is there's sort of a fulfillment in
that repetition that I've I've come to
enjoy actually these last 10 to 14 days
of alright accepting this is the process
currently and I'm going to make the best
in the present moment right of this
process it's really the only way
acceptance yep you know railing against
what is will only lead to resentment and
frustration yeah so to embrace what's
happening
and shift your perspective and look at
it as you know I think it helps to
understand that everybody's going
through it you haven't been you know
singled out for this experience is
helpful but the only way to find peace
is through acceptance for sure for sure
and it is also with regards to like you
were talking about being sort of stuck
with this lack of compass and direction
currently as we pull back to the
training aspect in the athlete aspect
but the athletes mindset is exactly that
like you said their awareness to stay in
the moment and do the best you can do at
the task at hand
whatever that task is right if it's
currently with my family or currently at
at work or currently in this process of
training or currently you know going on
a hike and noticing nature around us
like that that's all we can focus on and
that's the best place to focus on in the
current moment in the present moment
yeah
have you had any athletes that are just
completely unraveling yes yes absolutely
I mean don't get me wrong I'm probably
busier than ever currently just because
so many are at home and a have more time
to Train or being a lot more ideas
exactly a lot more emails a lot more
phone calls I'm also taking this time
like I was talking earlier about going
everybody's going over everybody's
running form and cycling form and
stretch cord form or those that can open
water swim and they're all sending me
video so I'm going through that but
there are definitely those who are
completely off the rails uh-huh you know
and and there's those just as on the
other end of the spectrum that are
completely unmotivated it's and they
just it's like alright well I know I can
get to a certain level of fitness again
and I it's hard to argue against that
the only part that I say there is that
when we come out of this in that future
version of ourselves how long will it
come to get back to par and get to where
you want to get to versus staying
somewhat
sipar and then just increasingly effort
the training the fitness that piece that
you want to get you to your event mm-hmm
doubling up on that is a lot I mean
that's gonna take a serious long amount
of time if you take the next four months
completely off and do nothing
mm-hmm so that's another thing to keep
in mind there's a basic maintenance
level that our body can be just a few
weeks removed from getting back to
basically par fitness being pretty fit
but not you know perfectly primed for an
event and that's sort of where we want
to bubble right now just below the
surface of okay I'm maintaining a
healthy body that it is strong enough
and healthy enough in order to then up
the training when that urgency when that
time comes again the other thing that
other athletes have noticed is those
that are completely over trained and
keep adding stuff they're realizing by
doing less how much better they're
sleeping how much better they're feeling
they're coming out of that thought oh
that's interesting
they're coming out of that fog of
fatigue for the first time going wow I
didn't even really realize how tired I
actually was I'm like right you go yeah
that's great yeah I I think it's worth
mentioning also that if you are one of
those people who just can't summon up
any motivation right now or or this
crisis is hitting you in a in a very
acute way that that's okay too I think
there's this sense like Oh everybody you
know you go on Instagram and everybody's
doing these crazy challenges and you
feel bad if you're not doing that like
if you're if you're you know not feeling
it it's okay to accept that in yourself
and just try to figure out what it is
that that you can do and not try to hold
yourself to some standard that you set
prior to what is occurring right now
remember you are still an athlete based
off of your mindset and what you're
learning and what you're recovering and
how you're eating it you don't have to
put all five pieces of being an athlete
into every day in order to call yourself
an athlete or live the life of an act
getting good sleep taking care of
yourself good nutrition can be plenty
and that you're growing and learning
just from that the mindset is all about
as an athlete what am i doing to take
care of myself and if currently that
means doing no training but focusing on
sleep and learning more and reading more
or spending more time in with family and
investing yourself in other areas so be
it you're still an athlete you still
have the mindset of an athlete because
you're thinking like one and you're
applying yourself like one I've had a
couple conversations with some Olympians
and perspective Olympians and it's been
interesting to gauge how they're
navigating the fact that the Olympics
are not happening for another year I
mean can you imagine knowing it you know
yeah it's like as a two-time Olympian
yourself you know better than anyone
what's required of yourself to prepare
for something like that your entire life
is about that yes and then to be told
it's not happening for another year or
you know we're not gonna even select the
team until next year it's potentially
career-ending and devastating and what's
been cool is to talk to a few people and
to see it kind of you know not
nonchalance but the positivity like okay
well that's part of the training like I
trained for this like we'll just you
know I'll meet that I'll meet that
obligation when I'm forced to yeah
compartmentalizing is something
Olympians yeah do better than I know
anybody right and what can we learn from
that you know yeah yeah I mean it's it
is like you said staying in the moment
and doing the best at the current task
at hand
to your abilities you don't control more
than that at any point in time you might
give yourself a story that you're in
control of more than that but you're not
and
I still feel for those guys though and
girls because there's so much that's
happening there and with regards to
their one opportunity maybe their one
window putting off law school or medical
school or graduate school because you're
gonna give it that shot and now you have
to make that decision for another year
or not or you're on the back end of your
career and you've just missed it at the
last Olympics and now you're progressing
just fine but you're getting to the back
end of your age there's so much there's
it's like the tentacles of this go
forever
you're on how it impacts so many
different lives and people you know from
families to children to all these things
to incomes it's crazy how big that
machine is and everybody has a story
right it I can't get caught up thinking
about it because whenever I talked to
Emily about it and we just sit there and
it's my brain starts moving in that
direction
it just it starts hitting me from so
many different directions of all the
ways this impacts these Olympians is
it's it's devastating
in a lot of aspects yeah but they don't
think of it like that just like you said
it's like I only can do the best next
workout that's all I can think of and
that's how they've been thinking all
their lives so it's a simple it stays
within that simple process for them how
do I prepare myself for the next best
possible workout with recovery with
sleep with proper nutrition and then go
execute that and layer upon layer upon
layer and when the day comes I know that
I've done everything I need to do to to
be ready for it beyond that there's
nothing I can do yeah control the
controllables you know the person who
who self destructs when faced with an
obstacle like this is not the person
that is the person who's going to the
Olympics yeah you know these people are
Jedi Masters when it comes to facing and
and managing obstacles this perhaps
being you know one of the largest that
that athletes are collectively facing
but the ones that will prevail I think
are the ones who have the firmest and
most
positive mindset yes to manage it sure
and then the question will be is in
other Olympics three years away and then
comes the next kind right yeah exactly
do you have an opportunity to get to the
base in three years that's exactly and
there you could you could be I went to
two Olympics and it was in a matter of
like you know two and a half years right
yeah like you're done great the
uncertainty is them is the most
maddening aspect of it
like once you say okay this is when it's
gonna be you can start to plan and wrap
your head around it but not knowing
creates a paralysis that that I think is
you know potentially more difficult to
deal with them than anything else yeah
and then your current training right so
then now you can't even execute properly
let's say you are a sueldo know when
what the window is well but also let's
say you're an Olympic swimmer right now
and you were just getting ready for
trials this summer and now you can't
even swim so you can't even do the task
that is your sport on a daily basis so
that talk about taking it away all the
control don't you do one controllable
that you had was alright go to the pool
execute my workout and feel good about
that well currently you can't even do
that so I mean there's definitely many
other stories like that but we we you
and I can relate best to the swimming
aspect and just doing that every day and
waking up and going my simple task that
done all my life twice a day or been my
day's been revolved around is gone right
and and also I was so close to achieving
my lifelong dream and so forth but I
mean it's the same with how many college
athletes are and finishing up their
senior year at NC double-a and so forth
and it's across the board how many
levels this hits I mean here we talk
about
well our pools closed for masters
swimming or we can't go on our trails
but I think the stories beyond this it
was interesting that it took quite a
long time before they pulled the plug on
the Olympics I was just thinking these
swimmers the pools are closed all over
the world I can't they can't train like
they're supposed to are you gonna
all this olympics are not like there
they can't even prepare right now well
there was that equalizing factor of that
bill right if they're all not swimming
right I guess this is sort of what would
that look like everybody shows up they
haven't trained it all and partially but
I what we're talking a miniscule little
group that we're talking about right now
you and I and what we can relate to just
think of the enormity in so many other
sports and so many industries that are
reliant on the Olympics I mean he's such
a huge thing that touches so many
people's lives that aren't even athletes
mmm all the you know all the support
systems with it and responsive so it's
just I think they they they were just
struggling with how do you pull the plug
on something like this yeah yeah
interesting times well I want to round
this out with two last-minute things the
first is we should probably recap Otello
a little bit and give a shout out to
Michael and and and motts we were both
there although we didn't even see each
other which is no crime yeah it was we
both were able to experience the island
and that race it was pretty cool yes and
it was pretty magical to sort of have
now in hindsight again it was an
experience that you look back on and you
go wow that was a window of time that
now became a lot more meaningful because
of everything stopped since then yeah so
a unique place what a challenging great
event those hills and that course at
first I was a little skeptical when I
was like how are you gonna just do this
by swimming from one beach to the other
mmm but it really was magical beautiful
the water was crystal clear crazy um it
was crazy and you're a few miles from LA
and I'm not saying that la is the
dirtiest water but it's also not that
clear as it was I'm not even close like
I I was just thinking oh this is what
Los Angeles must have been like 200
years ago yeah you know so the coasts
the coves were beautiful the runs were
beautiful that views were beautiful it
was really hard though I mean it was a
very challenging course
from my perspective the downhills really
beat you up but that's exactly the way
moths and Mike want it right Michael is
just sort of laughing going okay if you
think anybody can do an Attila or like
you always says in the intro is like
this is not Iron Man just refrain yes
and so within the first half mile that
race going straight uphill that nobody
can run and many people are on all fours
sort of working their way up that's like
all right well you you took the anything
is possible might ride through right
there yeah but great event great job by
them by way of background for people
that are listening who aren't familiar
Oh till Oh is a series of multi sport
races that involve swimming and running
they're in locations throughout Europe
and the one in Catalina was Otello's
first North American race so Chris and I
wanted to go and participate and support
we had been teammates you do this in
teams of two we were teammates in Sweden
a couple years ago you do the whole
thing in a wetsuit and your running
shoes your running trails your jumping
in the water your climbing on rocks and
doing all kinds of crazy stuff and I too
was thinking well how is this going to
go when it's just one island you're not
going island to island and I had teamed
up with my buddy mark who works with you
as well and he had a family conflict at
the last minute so we were unable to
participate in the longer race that you
competed in and we did the shorter race
the day before which was in the moment
that that happened I was somewhat
disappointed and thinking this is why
you know I do this stuff myself and I
don't have to rely on anyone else but
then I got my ass handed to me it was
even though I did the shorter one which
still took two hours it wasn't you know
it wasn't like a tiny right he was still
to our race so it was really hard and I
thought man it's a good thing I did the
full one because I would have really
gotten strung out on that yeah the hills
were crazy but the swims were
a bowl the water temperature was perfect
the clarity in the water was amazing and
as always those guys put on an
incredible experience and it was great
to see so many people having that
experience for the first time and also
conversely to see so many Europeans
coming to America to experience it for
sure it definitely had an international
flavor yeah but it still had their
Otello flavor and then Michael and matza
put on and it just it was done really
well and I felt like I was in Europe for
a little bit there yeah just the with
the vibe of it and they put it on this
island that is definitely unique
Catalina's definitely a unique spot you
know stopped in time so you're not in
Avalon you're in the other little too
harbors area which is much less traveled
it's a very different version of
Catalina than one might expect or what
you would imagine if you've been to
Avalon for sure and beautiful though I
mean the sailboats and the views in the
color of the water I mean definitely
felt like you have somewhere else versus
off the coast of California
the biggest difference other than you
know there wasn't down pouring rain and
freezing temperatures like we had in
Sweden was that you really did have to
run in this one like in Sweden it was so
technical for so much of the course and
this it was it was legitimate trial
running and much less technical for sure
but also a lot steeper running harder
fire roads and trails that you don't
have in the European ones as much as at
least the one that we've experienced I
shouldn't say all the Europeans but we
haven't done that but the trails here
were definitely challenging I mean I was
quite surprised how hard it was yeah all
right well let's round this thing out
yet maybe leave us with a few quick
shots of inspiration and wisdom for the
athlete who's listening right now who is
stuck in their house and trying to find
some semblance of sanity and their
relationship to their fitness yeah I
mean there's still many things that you
can do from home and as we talked about
with regards the different exercises of
step ups and
jump rope and stretch cords and you can
be a pretty complete athlete whether
it's triathlete or running athlete or
endurance athlete in your home with all
the tools available these days but the
other thing is to keep in mind as they
say willpower is mastering the tension
of not getting what you want in the
moment and what willpower do you want to
show in order to get something for a
future outcome whatever that might be
and so constantly reminding yourself how
do I want to kick out of this who do I
want to be not as a big-picture
perspective person but what kind of
athlete do I want to be kicking out of
this and what do I want to integrate
that I can learn currently in my home
with the smaller exercises or the step
ups or running with a step box with a
vest or doing the staircase in your
building a variety of times there's so
many different exercises and types of
training you could do and as we said
earlier don't overlook the fact that
just because you're not training there's
other modalities of being an athlete
that you can be very successful in and
learning skills and techniques that you
will have on the other side of this to
integrate once the events start ramping
back up again and things start loosening
back up again and you can be the athlete
that you like to be in everyday right we
all have that athlete within us how do
we let it come out and shine and come
forward and so connecting with that I
think is very important in this time
awesome dropping the truth bombs as
always I love it
I appreciate you you mentioned that you
had put up you're putting up some
content or some videos like stretch cord
exercises and things like that is there
a place where people can go and enjoy
some of that yeah as I put in a variety
of videos for this for stretch cords on
the aimed coaching website and then also
in there I have stretched cord workouts
so you don't necessarily for swimmers
listening and for open water swimmers
and triathletes you don't necessarily
just want to do a bunch of poles there's
ways to go about stretch cord workout
that it mimics your swim stroke very
closely just for a second here rich
what's interesting and you can relate as
a swimmer
you know how many strokes you do per
length and so per arm let's say that's
eight strokes let's say you do sixteen
strokes or fourteen strokes per length
so seven per arm well you can start
counting so that's 28 per hundred so if
you do 28 poles on a stretch cord with
an arm that's a hundred and so you can
start building a swim practice around
the same concept and it's interesting
with the Garmin watches or the Kouros
watches that we wear these days it does
your stroke count for you yeah and so
you just look that up you do your poles
and quickly in an hour you realize you
swam almost the same amount right that
you did right it's crazy yeah and then
throw it at its resistance base so
you're building strength whilst doing a
swimming motion and so there's a little
bit more rest that you need an other
fatigue but let's say you mix in jump
roping and in between and the rest or
you do some core work now you just did
an amazing hour in 15 minutes you helped
your swimming you were technically sound
because if you watch that video you can
see the importance on some of these
pointers and you walk it away going that
was an amazing workout and I did it in a
square footage of eight hmm
so little things to keep in mind again
so that you can come out of this armed
with more knowledge to apply however you
want to apply it for the athlete you
want to be so yeah that's on the website
and then I also put a bunch of cycling
intervals up there every week so that
you can log in and just see I put all
the last years of cycling intervals out
there for free so that in case you're
bored by any type of Swift riding or so
on you just want to do something with a
specific focus it's all on the website
that's great if you're a swimmer and you
don't have stretch cords definitely pick
up a pair it's a it's a must-have most
swimming apparel manufacturers make a
version of that or you can just purchase
surgical tubing on the internet off
Amazon and make your own which is what
we used to do back in college even if
you're not a swimmer it's just a great
very simple thing to improve your lats
your shoulders there's all kinds of
exercises that you can do with it and
you know
by like a full weight set and you can
bring it wherever you go doesn't weigh
anything together so a great little yeah
tool for people who are looking to do
something a little bit different all
right man well thanks so much this is
great
of course I appreciate a iymp coaching
calm at AI MP coach on all the social
media platforms this is like your 300th
appearance on the podcast and there will
be many more to come I'm sure meanwhile
you're doing your weekly Word podcast
the zoom calls are just for your
athletes though right doesn't open to
the public
yep and the podcast I just try to again
keep everybody motivated keep them
focused and as I was saying to you
earlier today I want most people most
people putting a little quote the air
quotes around that does not think about
how long this current situation will
take instead I want them thinking of how
far can I grow or how how far can I take
this in this time instead wisdom is
always alright well next time I see you
hopefully we'll be out in nature doing
something fun together
except you finally oh you know it's on
point alright appreciate it thanks man
talk to you soon
[Music]
what a gem that guy is I love him so
much if you vibed with Chris and his
words hit home with you I suggest you
check out his previous appearances on
the show he was on episode 21 256 297
how about 313 329 377 415 and 437 I
suggest you also hit up Chris's podcast
the weekly word podcast to learn more
about Chris visit the episode page on my
website at rich WorldCom and you can
visit him at AI MP coaching com you can
also find him on twitter and instagram
at a IM p coach if you'd like to support
the work we do here on the show
subscribe rate and comment on it on
Apple podcasts on Spotify and on youtube
share the show or your favorite episodes
with friends or on social media and you
can support us on patreon at rich roll
com forward slash donate thanks to
everybody who helped put on today's show
Jason camiolo for audio engineering
productions show notes and interstitial
music Blake Curtis and Margo lumen they
typically video the podcast but this one
was remote so no video
Jessica Miranda for graphics Ali Rogers
for portraits dk for advertiser
relationships and theme music as always
by tyler Pyatt trapper Pyatt and Harvey
Mathis thanks for the love you guys see
you back here in a couple days with
another amazing episode until then stay
safe remain engaged with your friends
and your family members try to move that
body find creative ways to engage with
your fitness and I will see you back
here soon till then peace
[Music]